when I faced off against the man in
yellow I won't make the same mistake
twice James the past Joe I'm gonna say
mom time isn't extremely fragile
construct how many more people could die
if your mother lives this is why you
became the flash to put things right
Barry we had talked about this I know
and I'm done talking you're not gonna
pay for another man's crime
he's the man that killed my mother I
know what you're thinking hey we need
your help we have the technology the
Adam lives take your last breath I'm the
queen of this house I'll show you what
it means to be stung bees why did it
have to be peace if I didn't know any
better i think that you were hiding
something from me
yeah what crack what do dr. wells and
the reverse-flash have to do with each
other they're the same person anybody
that knows about this is in the hell of
a lot of danger I warned you not to mess
with the timeline hello Cisco I don't
know anything anymore especially oh I
can and can't trust the real endgame is
almost here this is gonna be fun
and you never well
hey youtubers is charlie so they posted
a new flash trailer so there's going to
be a break down to that we got a bunch
of new footage of Emily Kinney and the
reverse-flash let's just start with a
really big stuff first team flash is
inside the Gideon computer room then we
see the reverse-flash inside one of the
metahuman prisons this is a little
timing why me just because he's standing
so at some point Barry finds out that he
is the reverse-flash and throws him in
prison who knows how they capture him
but we also see a redo of that scene
from episode 15 where Harrison wells
killed Cisco they said that they would
be revisiting that other timeline they
didn't say how they just said
interesting ways so it seems like
Barry's going to continue to play with
the timeline we also get a better
explanation for what's going on with
Eddie Thawne and why Barry Allen is
fighting another version of the flash
that looks just like him there's a
chameleon rogue that can assume the form
of other people so when Eddie Thawne is
killing these two cops it's probably
that rogue just disguised as Eddie
Thawne there's like a brief shot of
Gorilla Grodd breaking through a wall
here that's not till episode 21 that's
like right up into the finale so like
whatever Grodd does it's going to lead
directly into the finale because usually
the finale is kind of like a three-part
thing even though it's technically three
separate episodes episode 22 is like the
last big rogue team up episode with
these three guys most of the Rogues that
you've seen the back half of the season
are all going to team up with a few from
the first part of the season think of it
as a homage to revenge of the rose but
they're they're been like several team
ups with the Rogues in the comics over
the years Emily Kenny's character here
actually makes some bee puns so I don't
know if that'll actually connect her to
hive but she literally says I am the
queen bee of this hive I don't know if
that will translate to hive the
organization we also have what you might
call a Snowberry moment with like Barry
kissing Caitlin but that could be the
chameleon rogue to the scene where the
atom flies into the back of the flash
van is actually from the Six Million
Dollar Man we have the technology we can
rebuild him Ray Palmer would be more
like the six billion dollar man just add
some special news from wondercon to they
confirmed for season two there will be
mirror master and dr. alchemy I know
everyone's just been waiting for mirror
master he's like the next biggest rogue
that they haven't done yet so I guess
they're just waiting for the right time
no idea whether or not his powers are
going to be tech based or whether he's
going to be a metahuman if you ever
wonder how
decide who gets the tech and who gets
the metahuman powers it's just like the
smarter villains make their own tech or
in the case of Captain Cold he steals it
the Mardon brothers are the other side
of that coin you know not quite as smart
very good criminals not super tech based
so obviously they're going to be
metahumans they also confirmed that a
abarth on prime this guy here he'll be
back before the end of the season
presumably in a flashback but they did
say that Harrison wells as we see him
right now like the Harrison wells
reverse flash there are aspects of the
original Harrison wells personality in
there even though technically it's a bar
Thawne wearing a Harrison wells meat
suit so it's like when he absorbed his
DNA he absorbed some of his mind to the
actors have said that there's a lot of
potential for them to come back and
season two like really interesting
places to take their characters so even
if team flash defeats the reverse flash
in the finale it won't be the last of
Harrison wells Tom Cavanagh or a abarth
on here think of it as like Malcolm
Merlyn in season water or Slade Wilson
in season two villains that are this
much fun to watch are never going to be
gone completely Greg Berlanti also
teased that in this flashback scene when
we go to the night that Barry's mother
died something is different in episode
17 than the last time we saw this he
could have been referring to the
reverse-flash being the one to save
Barry Allen like child Barry Allen or he
could have also been referring to the
reverse-flash not being the one to kill
Nora Allen Barry's mother technically he
didn't go back to kill her mother I
think he went back in time to kill Barry
Allen as a child but they'll continue to
go back to that night so be sure to keep
your eyes peeled for like scenes that
are shot in different ways whenever we
go back and more flashbacks all in all
lots of awesome stuff to be really
excited about don't forget the flash is
back next week but no new episode this
week I'm probably going to do a Q&A just
for air on the flash this week because I
didn't do it last week so be sure to
subscribe to get that if there's any
special bonus videos you guys want me to
do then let me know there's got to be a
lot more game of thrones daredevil
related stuff happening is especially
like after Wednesday don't forget
daredevil all drops on netflix on friday
13 episodes they're all one hour long
and then Game of Thrones starts on
Sunday so if you guys haven't seen it
yet you can click here for my lash flash
trailer that I posted yesterday and you
can click here to start getting ready
for daredevil on netflix this weekend I
just
posted a non-spoilery review so thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow